Hello, how are you, Héctor Mejía greets you with
his informative brief, today is Wednesday the
first of September, the first group of
local firefighters are already in
Lake Tahoe to help contain the
fire in which the author arrived early
Tuesday morning, these 20
people are from
north clark county fire departments
dates and schedule 10 other
clark county units are helping in
the southern part of lake tahoe
the clark county school district board of directors will meet today
where they will vote on whether to vaccinate
the coronavirus is made
mandatory for employees this meeting
occurs after seeing several school districts in
the country pass this rule
for school staff
one of the reasons they are taking into
account is that many students are not
eligible to get vaccinated
on  The debate will begin at five in
the afternoon and continuing with the vaccinations there
will be many clinics around the
valle this week today for example there are
21 campus puentes teams with near
bonanza and sergio from one to four in the
afternoon another in huesca to have been from 2 to 4
in the afternoon this clinic also offers
the flu vaccine
there will also be clinics inside  from the
airport they want me one is tomorrow
in terminal 1 level 2 from 1 to 3 in the
afternoon for a complete list you can
enter our online page or
social networks now take a look at
the weather forecast today we will have a
cloudy Wednesday with temperatures
barely reaching  At 94 degrees
we have chances of rain for the
valley and tomorrow the sun will return with a
maximum of 97 however the drizzle will return
for the long weekend
have a nice day I am Héctor Mejía and
this was your brief Spanish x-men newsletter